leles parents et les éducateurs,
leles enseignants et le personnl
dede soutien dans les écoles.
VoVoici mon reportage.
- - Les masques, qui devaient
prprotéger nos enfants et le
pepersonnel qui veille sur eux,
popourraient s'avérer nuisibles
popour leur santé. Santé Canada
vivient d'émettre une mise en
gagarde relative aux masques
SNSNN-200-642. Une évaluation
prpréliminaire des risques
a a révélé un potentiel
dede toxicité pulmonaire
prprécoce, liée à l l'inhalation
dede graphènene nanoformé.
- - J'en ai pris une avant que
vovous commenciez votre cours.
- - Les ministèreres québécois
dede la Famille, de l'Éducation
etet de l'Enseignement supérieur
rerecommandent donc
auaux établissements visés
dede cesser immédiatement
d'd'utiliser ces masques.
GuGuy Bolduc est très s inquiet.
SaSa fille a porté prèss
d'd'une centaine de ces masques
dedepuis bientôt t 3 mois.
GUGUY BOLDUC
- - Ma fille me disait... m'a dt
sosouvent, en sortant de l'écol:
"P"Papa, j'ai l'impression que
j'j'ai des poils dans la bouche
avavec ce masque-là".
T'T'sais, elle toussait, elle
ététernuait. Quand elle enlevait
lele masque, ça se régéglait,
c'c'était toujours comme ça.
- - Les syndicats aussi sont
prpréoccupés de la situation.
SOSONIA ÉTHIER, présidente,
CeCentrale des syndicats du Qc
- - Qu'est-ce qu'on fait, , lun?
LuLundi là, dadans certains
ététablissements, dans certaines
gagarderies, est-ce qu'on va
avavoir des masques sécuritaire?
- - Les milieux de garde
avavaient déjà étété échaudés
papar une situation similaire.
DeDes masques non conformes
avavaient été distribués dans le
réréseau entre mai et novembre.
LULUCIE LONGCHAMPS, v.-p., Fédé.
dede la santé et des serv. socix
- - C'est la deuxièmeme fois
ququ'on envoie, dans le réseau,
dedes masques qui ne répondent s
auaux exigences. Dans la premièe
fofois, c'était qu'ils ne
rérépondaient pas totalement
auaux conformités. Cette fois-c,
onon nous parle d'un danger
popotentiel pour la travailleus,
papar le fait des matériaux
avavec lesquels ils sont faits.
- - De quoi ébranler la confiane
dedes parents, mais aussi de tot
lele personnel des écoles et des
gagarderies concernées, à l'a'ae
d'd'une troisièmeme vague.
I Ici Julie Emond,
R Radio-Canada, Montréa